you've mentioned already that um this is  this is fun for you this feels good this  is it's compelling you can't stop so I  guess do you think is that one  philanthropy is at its most effective is  when it's not even some sort of  sacrifice it's sort of this idea of  enlightened self-interest you you want  to give is that when it's at its best  absolutely I absolutely do and I think  that's the interesting about the the  time talent vs vs fundraising that I am  I don't I expect you could potentially  have that feeling if you gave enough  money or to the right thing and have the  right effect but it's very clear to me  that everybody that I work with as a  Yale volunteer at the aoa yo women in  other places has that you know  enlightened self-interest positive  feedback loop going on which makes it  easy to to keep doing it